hey this is pretty cool for the first
time ever time magazine has named
someone their kid
of the year she's a 15 year old
scientist and inventor from colorado
named getanjali rao
she's very impressive they apparently
considered over 5 000 nominees before
choosing a winner
one of those nominees actually contacted
our show
to ask if he could come on to give a
quick congratulations to
catanjali i thought that was very nice
so here he is please welcome
thane montgomery thane hello
this is very nice of you i understand
you want to personally congratulate
time's official kid of the year
yeah not really conan that's just
something i said to get past your
producer
oh you don't want to congratulate the
winner are you
are you upset that you didn't win or
something uh you think
i actually wasn't even nominated even
though i'm a thousand times better than
every other kid out there including the
so-called winner
what do you mean so-called winner i mean
she invented a device that detects lead
in drinking water so she seems like a
perfect choice
yawn conan you know what's actually
difficult sneaking laxative into my
dad's drinking water without him
noticing
i've already done that like eight times
this week guess where he is right now
i i don't really know or sitting on the
can
okay you know thane that's just a prank
that's a mean prank that's not what kid
of the year award is all about
my dad's already been to 12 different
doctors and nobody can figure out what's
wrong with his intestine
i'm smarter than 12 doctors conan no
you're not that doesn't make sense
this year's winner she works with
genetics and artificial intelligence
that's real cutting edge science
i invented cutting edge science i've
toilet papered my mom's car
every day since march i'm half the
reason there was a toilet paper shortage
now that's kit of the year material it's
just no
that's wasteful and cra no i just forget
it zayn
feign whatever your name is and how many
kids know to use a burner phone for all
their prank phone calls
i learned that from the wire you watch
the what your parents let you watch the
wire
let me how would they know my mom's
always cleaning toilet paper off her car
and my dad's on the can oh yeah great
you know what you're not you're not kid
of the year material fain
hey conan i got two kids of the year
right here for you oh that's
that's classy that's great thane that's
really class
yeah do you have any friends thane
uh-huh yeah how many like
12 12 friends
name two of them this one
and this one oh you know what okay screw
you
thane you must get a fan conan not a fan
oh oh i'll live i'll lift feign what am
i gonna do without thane as a fan
hey conan i wanna introduce you to two
of your biggest fans
one and two okay you keep falling for it
really
i didn't fall for it you didn't give me
a chance or whatever
all right thane do me a favor please go
right now
back to school and get this [ __ ] kicked
out of you okay
i can't because of covid just don't
contact the show again okay